Narrator:
WITH THE HUNGER CLOCK TICKING,
JAMIE DECIDES THERE'S ONLY
ONE SOLUTION -- SPEAR FISHING.
THERE WE GO.
AND WHILE MOTHER NATURE DOES
PROVIDE THE MAIN COMPONENT...
GIVE IT UP, TREE.
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE.
...DUCT TAPE IS
AN INTEGRAL PART.
MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THAT.
Jamie: THERE ARE THREE THINGS
THAT I CAN DO WITH THE DUCT TAPE
TO HELP MAKE A SPEAR.
FIRST, IT'LL ALLOW ME
TO ATTACH AND EASILY REPLACE
MULTIPLE POINTS ON THE TIP --
PERFECT.
I DARESAY ANY
LITTLE FISH OR CRITTER
WOULDN'T REALLY WANT
TO GET STUCK BY THAT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND I CAN ALSO USE IT TO MARK
THE BALANCE POINT OF THE SHAFT,
WHICH WILL HELP WITH ACCURACY.
THERE WE GO.
AND FINALLY, THE LINE ON THE END
WILL HELP ME RETRIEVE IT
ONCE I'VE THROWN IT.
I'M GONNA GO CATCH ME
SOME FISH.
WELL, WHAT I'VE GOT TO DO
IS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD --
SPOT A FISH AND SPEAR IT.
Narrator:
LIKE SNARING A CHICKEN,
IT SOUNDS EASY IN THEORY.
OKAY, FISH. HOLD STILL.
OH!
BUT IN PRACTICE...
YEAH!
...IT'S A BEACH.
OH!
I'M NOT LEAVING HERE
WITHOUT DINNER.
Narrator:
ON THE PLUS SIDE, THOUGH,
THE DUCT-TAPE SPEAR'S
HOLDING UP WELL.
Jamie: I LIKE MY LITTLE
STRING -- WORKED LIKE A TREAT.
NOW, IF I CAN JUST GET THE FISH
TO HOLD STILL.
JUST LIKE FISHING
WITH A ROD AND REEL,
SPEAR FISHING
IS ALL ABOUT PATIENCE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE
GONNA SIT THERE LIKE DUCKS
AND WAIT FOR YOU TO SPEAR THEM.
YOU'VE GOT TO JUST HANG OUT,
WAIT FOR THE RIGHT TIME...
AND THEN THROW.
Narrator: AND THERE'S NO TIME
LIKE THE PRESENT.
[ SHOUTS ]
YEAH!
ABOUT TIME!
Narrator:
AT LAST, HE'S NAILED IT.
OH, YEAH, BABY!
SUSHI FOR DINNER!
Narrator: IT'S A GREAT RESULT.
SORRY, LITTLE BUDDY.
IT'S FOR A GOOD CAUSE.